le problème c'est que certes il ya
plusieurs scénarios qui parle de sortir
du nucléaire et des énergies fossiles en
parallèle c'est vrai que c'est pas dit
strictement antinomiques et on est sur
un défi qui est considérable qui est la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
aujourd'hui si on veut atteindre 2
degrés de réchauffement voire même 25
ans commencent à parler de capter le
carbone aux sorties centrales à charbon
pour le séquestrer on est sur un niveau
de complexité qui est extrêmement élevé
donc à chaque fois qu'on va se retirer
parce qu'on a peur ce qu'on refuse de
supprimer à risque plutôt que le
maîtriser et l'équilibré on va augmenter
le risque de ne pas réussir à atteindre
si l'otiv climatique et avec des
conséquences qui sont probablement bien
plus fâcheuses bien plus globale et à
long terme que tout ce qu'on peut
envisager pour le nucléaire
[Musique]